l'opération barkan en marge d'un sommet
union européenne union africaine à
bruxelles le président français a réuni
ce soir plusieurs dirigeants africains
et européens pour discuter de la
présence militaire au sahel et de la
lutte contre le terrorisme le mali et le
burkina faso ne sont pas invités en
raison des coups d'état alors comment en
est on arrivé là abarkan est il un échec
comment organiser un retrait du mali et
un redéploiement des forces militaires
françaises et européennes quelle
sécurité pour le sahel on en débat avec
mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés le général giraud ma
pellistrandi bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue défense
nationale bienvenue dans le débat en
face de vous vincent hugeux bonsoir
vincent journaliste indépendant et
essayiste enseignant à sciences po
auteur de ça c'est votre dernier livre
tyran d'afrique et séchée elle paiera
également avec nous ces ripailles un
cyril bonsoir je crois reporter à france
24 qui revient tout juste du mali nous
avons également avec nous par skype de
bamako nour saar membre du conseil
national de transition est également
président du parti front africain pour
le développement à bonsoir à vous et
bienvenue également bonsoir pour cadrer
le débat vincent que je voudrais démarré
avec vous à pau en 2020 emmanuel macron
avait décidé de renforcer le dispositif
militaire deux ans plus tard la force
barkan se retire du mali que s'est il
passé est ce que c'est un peu chronique
d'un échec français comme le titre le
journal libération on va se garder de
toute lucidité rétrospective c'est trop
commode mais ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on
a quand même quelques-uns à décrire
cette mission dès l'origine comme une
mission impossible dont les forces
françaises s'acquitte avec une certaine
bravoure ce qui s'est passé depuis pau
c'est qu'au fond le scénario rose qui
avait été esquissé à l'époque celui
d'une réduction de voilure graduelle du
dispositif barkan accompagné d'une
focalisation s'appelle la zone des trois
frontières à aux confins du mali niger
burkina faso eh bien je dirais que ce
bel ordonnancement il a volé en éclats
sous l'impact de différents phénomènes
dont évidemment le coup d'état au mali
qui a modifié assez profondément les les
inconnues de l'équation alors sur
l'échec à quelle aune juge-t-on de la
réussite ou de l'échec ne cassons
militaires les budgets initiaux ont ils
été remplies ou pas si on ne s'imaginait
qu'il était possible d'éradiquer en
quelques années le fléau djihadistes
c'est qu'on se bercer d'illusions il
s'agissait de le contenir de le freiner
ensuite si c'est un échec car oui c'en
est un encore une fois au regard des
missions qu'on s'était assignée et côté
français ce n'est pas que l'échec de la
france est en tout cas pas que l'échec
de la de l'entité militaire ça va être
un échec en parti politique il ya eu des
erreurs de stratégie diplomatique été
commise et puis il y aussi un échec de
la gouvernance malienne qui d'abord n'a
jamais assumé les conséquences des
accords qui avaient été conclus dix
accords d'alger entre les parties
malienne et puis aussi qu'ils n'avaient
jamais véritablement
redéployer quelque chose qui ressemblait
à une administration fonctionnelle sur
le territoire et puis c'est aussi et je
termine là dessus à la marge peut être
les chèques ou en tout cas dire et le
retard à l'allumage de partenaires
européens qu'on a eu beaucoup de mal à
convaincre et la france porte une part
de responsabilité d'ailleurs là-dessus
que sept ans je n'étais pas une histoire
post coloniale franco malienne ou franco
sahélienne mettez un enjeu de sécurité
globale général jérôme pellistrandi vous
êtes d'accord barkan c'est un échec
je pense que comme l'a dit vincent la
problématique n'est pas d'ordre
militaire elle est d'ordre politique il
n'y a pas eu d'erreur militaire de
commise
rétrospectivement on peut toujours
estimer que telle ou telle action n'a
pas été forcément pertinente mais la
réalité c'est la problématique d'ordre
politique sur le plan militaire nous
avons obtenu un certain nombre de succès
tactiques qui ont amené à réduire la
menace elle s'est transformée ce qui
veut dire aussi qu'il faut transformer
les modes d'action pour lutter contre
cette menace changez donc de dispositifs
et bien entendu la problématique et les
dans cette confrontation qui s'est
installé après le coup d'état avec les
autorités maliennes mais le fait d'avoir
renforcé les troupes justement à pau est
ce que c'était une mauvaise décision ce
que c'était une erreur non anxiété
dans le contexte
tactique stratégique de l'époque il
fallait renforcer maintenant toute la
difficulté était a été de pouvoir
associer nos partenaires européens et
nos partenaires africains sachant que la
méfiance notamment entre les partenaires
africains a été un obstacle extrêmement
complexes à surmonter donc louis au
final la tâche est elle possible la
question elle est posée sur la table on
aurait dû s'imposer avant
c'est toujours difficile sur difficile
de revoir de regarder rétrospectivement
mais bon c'est intéressant on va voir
d'ailleurs ces images tournées par cyril
payen qui est avec nous à cyril au mali
la dernière fois que vous y étiez c'est
à dire la semaine dernière ce sentiment
anti-français qui est un sentiment
majoritaire au mali alors qu on se
souvient qu'il ya neuf ans eh bien les
forces françaises avaient été accueillis
à bras ouverts on regarde
manifestement cyril il reproche à la
france en tout cas de ne pas avoir été
efficace ces maliens qu'on va voir dans
un petit instant
oui effectivement oui à la question
c'est de savoir aussi quelle proportion
prend dans la population malienne ce
sentiment et je précise que c'est pas
encore un sentiment anti français c'est
un sentiment anti barkan un épuisement
face aux résultats de cette campagne
extérieur anti jihadistes et puis un
sentiment anti politique française donc
oui on verra peut-être ces images on est
conspué et insulté
évidemment mais sa dacia ne reste que
des mots on va le regard des temps
difficiles voilà de voir exactement là
la propension des gens qui pensent à
cette nouvelle manifestation est
organisée par le groupe pear et golo
buffo les remparts le noyau dur des
jeunesses nationalistes malienne et
tourne rapidement à la diatribe anti
françaises
[Musique]
tél
et la vente de matelas
[Applaudissements]
c'est le don pour eux c'est un échec
marc khanne pour ces maliens dans la rue
je crois que cela parce que encore une
fois c'est le noyau dur de gens qui sont
dans ces dans une course un peu une
course panafricanisme souverainiste très
populistes et qui est largement
instrumentalisée face à on verra plus
tard mais
je crois qu'ils ont dépassé ce stade
aujourd'hui il embrasse d'autres nations
il s'en passe d'autres causes et le but
aujourd'hui toujours de manifestations
qui sont importantes qui sont
hebdomadaires c'est que les français
quel qu'il soit ce sont haye nous
renouons mme sarr barkan quitte le mali
cette fois c'est sûr ça devrait être
annoncé d'ailleurs demain quelle est
votre réaction à ce que finalement vous
êtes satisfait du coup
bon il importe d'avoir deux places et
l'opération par contre dans son contexte
nous sommes en 2012 lorsqu'une horde de
dialyse avancer vers le sud du mali les
autorités légitimes d'alors avait
sollicité les partenaires français pour
un appui aérien
résultat le malia puis couvrir une bonne
partie de son territoire mais
malheureusement
cette joie
cet enchantement n'a duré que quelques
temps on regarde le soutien des
autorités françaises au club d'arts mais
dépourvu de toute légitimité
c'est tout ça mais on sent que la risée
la ville malienne de kidal c'est là bas
que se planifie tout les attentats c'est
la bac organiser toutes les attaques et
sous
pratiquement la protection de forces
françaises il est important également
madame se dire que lorsque barkan
intervenait serval ensuite par cas la
situation sécuritaire était dégradée par
le nord n'est pas au centre aujourd'hui
c'est pratiquement dans le sud même si
l'armée nationale est en train de mener
des opérations pour neutraliser ces
forces négatives
dans notre culture madame
le la reconnaissance extrême celle de
données sont le nom d'un enfant à son
bienfaiteur beaucoup d'enfants maliens
s'appellera ce sera hollande ce n'est
pas pour rien si ce n'est pas rien mais
aujourd'hui est ce que justement vous
êtes satisfait du départ imminent de
barkan
bon je ne parlerai pas de satisfaire un
départ que satisfaire ou pas nous sommes
face à un échec et ne les autorités
légitimes du mali jusqu'à preuve du
contraire n'ont pas officiellement
demandé le départ de quelques
partenaires que ce soit en dehors des
officiels non mais disons que on avait
l'impression que la france était plus
désiré au mali
bon si le résultat attendu n'est pas au
bout du compte le soir eh bien les gens
se sont fortement interroger notre
peuple s'est interrogé sur la présence
de l'armée française au mali nous
désarmer les plus modernes au monde qui
en laisse et l'insécurité généralisée
donc sous ses yeux qui a trahi qui a
signé un accord que les autorités
actuelles ont demandé à avoir un accord
de défense pour les autres outils
actuels ont demandé à l'ue alors
légitimement
satisfait pas satisfait je pense que la
question n'est pas là la question est de
savoir qu'est ce que nous avons pu faire
beaucoup de ces 10 ans est ce qu'un
partant ils ont la france laisse
derrière elle une situation sécuritaire
qui s'est améliorée ou qui sait calculer
est-ce que les opérations de la phrase a
mené au sahel ont permis de neutraliser
ou
d'affaiblir les groupes jihadistes c'est
là la question c'est la question en tout
cas effectivement elle s'en va cette
force vincent jeu est ce que c'est un
divorce aujourd'hui entre la france et
le mali oui le divorce est consommé et
d'ailleurs au passage je fais observer
qu'au regard du droit international il
n'y a pas d'autorité légitime ou mali
aujourd'hui il y a un pouvoir de fait
qui est populaire singulièrement à
bamako et ça me permet d'ouvrir une
brève parenthèse dire que ce sentiment
cette hostilité manifeste à la présence
française est indéniablement palpable et
amplement effectivement instrumentalisés
par des acteurs locaux qui en ont fait
leur fond de commerce populiste et par
des lecteurs
étrangers qui rêvent de s'engouffrer
dans la brèche laissée par le départ de
la france mais plus vous est donnée de
bamako - ce sentiment est palpable et
moi j'ai des contacts réguliers avec des
amis maliens dans l'agent de gao dans la
région dogon un autour de bandiagara qui
me disent tous ça va trop vite ne partez
pas si vite nous on se sentait plutôt en
sécurité quand le dispositif barkan
était pleinement en place donc ça c'est
la première opération sur le divorce
écoutez c'est très simple il suffit de
regarder et d'écouter le verbatim des
interventions du premier ministre dé
facto donc choquel kokalla maïga
installé par les putschistes sa part de
l'assemblée générale de l'onu à
l'automne dernier avec l'abandon en
plein vol à la france et ça va jusqu'à
une intervention devant des ambassadeurs
invités à la primature voilà quelques
jours où ils suggèrent ils affirment
soyons clair que la france non seulement
a été inefficace mais qu'elle a été
complice des groupes terroristes donc il
lui demande de partir en affirmant c'est
ce que voulait dire est ce qu est un
déclencheur wagner dans cette histoire
générale jérôme impétrants dit ça à
jouer voudrais quand même revenir sur
les images que l'on a vues au début des
manifestations
quand on voit les panneaux et la haine
anti française bon moi je pense à nous
près de 60 soldats qui sont morts là bas
à tous nos blessés voir de telles images
ccc c'est terrible parce que on ya
consacré beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie on
sait dépenser pour le mali le groupe
wagner pose effectivement un vrai
problème il y a actuellement environ un
millier de combattants de wagner et je
le rappelle qui se paye sur la bête
malienne nous
nous avons bien d'un millier a mis un
millier et donc dont la mission première
est d'assurer la survie de la junte il
ne s'agit pas de combattre et de
réinstaurer une sécurité minimale c'est
protéger la junte donc effectivement à
un moment donné le divorce est consommé
et consommer et c'était un peu la france
ont la force wagner ce alors tel
discours en tout cas où celui-ci est
alors c'est faux souligne 10 décembre il
faut souligner aussi qu'il ya une longue
tradition
en pro russe enfin pro soviétique puis
pro russe au mali donc il ya aussi une
forme d'instrumentalisation et dans le
contexte géopolitique actuel pour moscou
c'est extrêmement intéressant de
déstabiliser bien sûr la position
française dans cette région la série de
vous qui étiez vous avez vu en fait vous
avez pratiquement palper rouler parce
wagner il ya eu pas plp puisque
justement on se fait trois fois que j'ai
vu en deux mois et là on voit c'était
mon avis les in alzhemed et du mali à
cathy seth gabel garnison où dort
d'ailleurs le colonel à 6 mio ita et
c'est vrai que les stars du moment
c'était l'attaché militaire russe qui
est un fonds spécial aïd et laissez-les
fille avec la foule or qui étaient ces
de foule je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est vrai qu'il y avait un rapport de
force qui était absolument flagrant
puisque la délégation française qui
avait été invité au dernier moment d'un
moment c'est une grande journée des
forces armées un stage rapportant jours
fériés faisait un peu un nez pointu et
ne parlait pas il y avait un ambassadeur
de chine qui parle parfaitement français
qui disait nous allons nous essayer de
régler la question politique au mali
renvoyer les nouvelles forces en
présence et ce que je veux dire sur la
question de wagner et pour avoir
travaillé en centrafrique on a peut-être
on va un peu peut-être vite en calquant
les scénarii centrafricaine se dire
comment on s'est fait les français se
sont fait déposséder je dirais de cette
zone d' influence avec le mali parce que
le mali n'est pas la centrafrique c'est
plus complexe
et j'ajouterais même que je n'aime pas
la preuve de nombre important de membres
de wagner mais là aussi on est rentrés
des deux camps dans une guerre
informationnelle et les russes ont
beaucoup beaucoup d' avance sur nous sur
ce point les français je veux dire par
là que il n'est pas nécessairement
importante pour le groupe wagner d'être
en grand nombre puisque le fantasme la
symbolique autour de ces paramilitaires
je dirais suffit à déclencher ce genre
de manifestation d'art qui sont
alimentées aussi par les par les russes
évidemment comme en centrafrique mais il
n'y a pas nécessairement besoin d'avoir
mille personnes qu'on va payer
extrêmement cherche quelqu'un en
centrafrique parce que les conditions ne
sont pas les mêmes je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de coopération militaire russe
sur le terrain et l'amalgamme suffi et
c'est là la force de moscou c'est à dire
de nous sans avoir nécessairement
énormément de paramilitaires sur le
terrain est bien de faire avancer ses
pions et de nos bouter dehors et noom
sarr les mercenaires russes de wagner
peuvent-ils remplacer justement la
france
mais madame permettez moi de dire
monsieur vincent la légitimité de la
transition politique au mali
puisse apercevoir le 14 janvier
et sur la question du groupe
sanaa le c'est scandaleux que des états
qui disposent de capacités
extraordinaires puissent continuer à
entretenir ces rumeurs là les autorités
légitimes du mali ont indiqué en outre
qu'il n'y a pas de groupe wagner qu'il
n'y a pas de groupe phare air c'est
comme ça il partie de la communauté
internationale
en 2001 a indiqué qu' ils disposaient
tous de la bombe atomique
pardonnez moi nous a dit qu'il n'y a pas
de milices il n'y a pas de para
militaires russes
omar soto c'est une pagaille et n ya pas
longtemps enfin franchement et vous
dites n'existe pas avait
il n'existe pas les autorités l'ont
indiqué le communiqué et personne n'a pu
démontrer jusqu'à preuve de contraire la
plus avancée la moindre que irréfutable
cons et qu'on décline d'identité de ses
militaires opérant russes qui sont là
qu'on le fasse il est clair lacoste ça
la france que ce soit l'union européenne
dispose quand même de capacité pour
décliner l'identité ils ont des services
spéciaux
assez rare en france ils disent qu elles
existent telles qu'elles sont présentées
mais ce qui existe en france on a dit
qu'il y avait la bombe atomique à nérac
on a fait la guerre aux financeurs
jamais dit ce temps là bas dit justement
s'est pas engagé
les en sécurité les américains ont dit
qu'ils avaient la bombe atomique en irak
et la communauté internationale les a
suivi une partie du moins sous la
communauté internationale les aciéries
avec les français c'est rohff ou tard
ensuite comme général évoque non on sait
on s'éloigne un petit peu du sujet nous
mme sarr c'était juste voilà c'était
wagner pour vous donc ne concurrence pas
la france la france en se retire il n'y
a pas de vague mais pourquoi il y à il y
avait des coopérants militaires russes
comme il ya des coopérants espagnols il
ya des coopérants alma il y a des
coopérants français jusqu'à leur
ressemble parce que barco n'est pas
encore parti c'est la même chose de mal
et à acheter des armes avec les russes
c'est normal qu'on nous apprennent à
entretenir à faire la maintenance et
quand le général évoque la junte il n'y
a pas de chance
enfin tous les ans il n'y a pas de
jeunes il y a des autorités légitimes il
ya une transition qui a été réclamé par
le peuple des centaines de milliers de
personnes sont sorties ont demandé le
départ de l'ancien régime voilà mais la
communauté internationale parle de coup
d'état est d'ailleurs le mali n'est pas
invité au sommet de bruxelles et le
burkina faso
on va avancer un petit peu dans le débat
pardonnez moi je voudrais justement
écoutez la réaction de maquis ce2 pas
macky sall pardon de alassane ouattara
le président ivoirien c'était il ya
quelques minutes on écoute
nous nous considérons que la lutte
contre le terrorisme quelque chose
d'essentiel pour le mali pour le burkina
pour le niger et pour les pays côtiers
donc le départ de barkan et de takouba
clé un vide nous sommes obligés
d'augmenter nos forces de défense nous
serons obligés d'accroître la protection
de nos frontières nous serons obligés
d'acheter des armes le lavoir
la professionnalisation la sonnette de
voir aussi les armées nationales doivent
régler les problèmes de sur nos
territoires nationaux et c'est cela
notre philosophie et nous ferons en
sorte que cela ça entretien exclusif au
france 24 est pour pour rfi on sent tout
de même que il regrette un peu ce départ
alassane ouattara des troupes françaises
dans son jeu et il a quelques raisons de
redouter les conséquences on sait très
bien que l'enjeu stratégique pour les
forces jihad x c'est précisément cette
poussée vers le flanc sud vers les zones
côtières et on l'a vu d'ailleurs
cruellement au bénin voilà peu il y à
des états qui sont infiniment
vulnérables j'évoque le bénin mais des
pays comme le togo le ghana et voir le
sénégal de macky sall président en
exercice de l'union africaine se sentent
également vulnérables en date limite
quand également pardon de la côte
d'ivoire également oui bien sûr puisque
la côte d'ivoire on sait que au nord de
la côte d'ivoire et des cellules réputé
dormantes jusqu'à maintenant mais qui
apparemment se sont se sont brutalement
réveillé qui ont agi dans les zones
frontalières un petit mot quand même sur
sur wagner il faudrait que notre ami
malien informe de ce qu'il sait
vladimir poutine lui-même qui récemment
avait plus que suggérer qu'il y avait
effectivement la présence de d'éléments
paramilitaires sur le sol malien je
ferme la parenthèse si vous le péril
tel qu'il est perçu par alassane
ouattara tel qu'il est également perçue
par nana akufo addo le privant du ghana
toute autorité qui vont se trouver à
paris puis à bruxelles à partir de ce
soir il est devenu non pas un fantasme
une hypothèse il est devenu une réalité
j'observe enfin un dernier point je
m'arrête là dessus c'est que n'oublions
pas que le mali tout légitime que soient
ses autorités de fait a été suspendue
des instances de l'union africaine
conformément à sa charte est frappé par
des sanctions que l'on peut percevoir à
bamako comme injuste mais des sanctions
par la cedeao alors je connais le
discours la cedeao c'est la marionnette
de la france on se calme ce qui est vrai
est là pour être tout à fait quoi nîmes
c'est que pendant longtemps la versanne
ouattara on envie de lui rappeler que
lui piliers de la cedeao a pris quelques
libertés avec l'esprit de sa
constitution pour briguer un troisième
mandat et puis le tchad est représenté
et le jaï représentés et là il ya
un mot s'il vous plaît
général jérôme pellistrandi justement
sur ce déploiement de la france
manifestement c'est le niger qui va
devenir l'allié privilégié de la france
est effectivement ça va être une sorte
de c'est déjà un peu une sorte de hub me
semble-t-il deux militaires de la région
est ce que c'est ce que va être
renforcée oui comme vous l'avez souligné
alors déjà il faut rappeler qu'il ya à
peine deux il n'y a plus que deux mille
deux mille deux cents soldats français
au mali donc déjà l'empreinte a été
réduite nous avons rendu trois bases aux
autorités aux forces armées maliennes et
dans de bonnes conditions c'est à dire
que ils ont pu récupérer les
installations que nous avions construite
et donc qui ça leur permet d'avoir des
points d'appuis et donc nous allons à la
fois effectivement diminuer notre
empreinte ou mali mais contribuer à
notamment à partir de niamey au niger
mais aussi avec nos partenaires
africains et c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important parce que ça va
être l'objet de discussions pour aider
nos partenaires africains on le voit un
certain nombre d'actions
locales et qui vont permettre notamment
la montée en puissance de ces armes et
on l'a vu c'était déjà le projet initial
oui mais on va accélérer en quelque
sorte parce que se réserve de
l'accélérer alors qu'on n'a pas réussi
justement louis parce que d'une part on
a quand même on sait puis plus au sud
sur des désarmés qui sont le plus plus
plus sérieuses qui ont eu le temps de se
de se construire et qui donc
demande cette aide pendant plomb à un
centre de lutte antiterroriste qui était
monté récemment en côte d'ivoire et qui
est particulièrement utile l'objectif
c'est que ce soit et comme le disait le
président ouattara que ce soit les
nations africaines qui assument leur
sécurité nous allons les aider mais
c'est à elle d'assurer leur sécurité en
syrie alors justement cette nouvelle
base ce retrait à niamey est ce que
niamey devient l'alliée privilégiée est
ce que le niger reste stable va rester
stable continuez à désirer la france
mais c'est difficile d'avoir un meilleur
allié qui peut être le niger puisque
effectivement ça il n'y a pas grand
monde en fait un aujourd'hui qui qu'ils
soient qui soit stable donc c'est une
bosse et une c'est un pari sur l'avenir
il n'y a pas beaucoup le choix mais on
sait et c'est un secret de polichinelle
que les relations ne sont pas parfaites
entre la france et le niger aujourd'hui
sur la question d'état major il y à des
frictions sur le transfert de la base
opérationnelle de commandement pardon de
djamena au tchad qui prévu depuis
longtemps qui devait donc
progressivement se déplacer vers niamey
ça ne se passe pas aussi bien puisqu'on
nous dit aujourd'hui que ça sera mixte
il ya une part qui va rester à djamena
au tchad et une part qui va aller à
niamey
ce n'est pas le scénario idéal et
d'ailleurs on le voit avec les réactions
des nigériens qui sont un peu sur des
oeufs avec leur propre opinion publique
et qui n'accepte pas pour l'instant
parce que ça se négocie sans doute ce
soir que la force taguba ou ce qu'il va
en rester c'est à dire la force spéciale
européenne et bien soit transféré dans
son commandement sait où certains de ses
effectifs au niger donc c'est à deux
c'est un jeu dangereux ou au sein duquel
et la france positionnée et et
l'engagement européen aussi vincent j'ai
discuté très récemment en tête à tête
avec un très proche du président mohamed
bazoum qui m'a
du niger à accueillir non pas un
transfert qui salit pas de ça mais en
tout cas quelque chose qui pourrait
ressembler à un qg délocalisé de takouba
cela dit paris oui pari risqué et
notamment en terme d'opinion domestique
d'opinion nationale n'oublions pas ce
qui s'est passé à terra lorsque ce qu'on
appelle le convoi maudit qui avait été
bloquée d'abord au burkina faso a
ensuite eu à se heurter à une
manifestation extrême gauche et il y a
eu trois morts et voit son nom trois ya
aura le même domaine je veux dire c'est
que l'assise politique du présent basim
kit apparaît aujourd'hui à l'évidence
comme le meilleur allié de paris
faute de combattants mais c'est un fait
les relations entre niamey et bamako
sont excécrables puisque dans
l'entourage du président gbagbo me
considère que le mal vient du mali qui
n'a en fait pas su éradiquer le
phénomène jihadiste sur son sol le
risque il est politique mohamed bazoum a
été très contestée et d'ailleurs terra
moi j'ai toujours été sidéré que le
convoi roulait à voie royale passe par
terre alors qu'il suffit de connaître un
tout petit peu la géopolitique locale
pour faire que tera est un bastion de
l'opposition de gens qui vont jusqu'à
contester parfois la nigériane it et du
présent bazoum et à contester les
résultats de l'élection présentielle
donc le niger prend un véritable risque
mais simplement les autorités locales
estiment qu'il n'y a pas d'autre voie
que celle là on va écouter mohamed
bazoum d'ailleurs c'était en novembre
dernier à niamey
nous sommes dans une relation
normale avec la france
dans tout le pays
ce soir il avait à nos côtés dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme aujourd'hui
la france est le pays qui concerne le
plus de sacrifices
nomme sarr que pensez vous alors du
redéploiement justement de barkan des
forces militaires françaises vers le nia
vers niamey vers le niger bon c'est une
question de souveraineté française c'est
aux français de décider où ils vont du
playback en essais aux nigériens
responsable nigérien de accueilli en
tout cas aussi que nous concerne comme
l'a indiqué le général la sécurité des
nations africaines doivent être prises
en charge par les africains qui le mali
s'y est mis nous avons des fortes
défense qui remonte en puissance et qui
aujourd'hui sont en opération sur
l'ensemble du territoire ou ramener la
sécurité vous avez dû vous rendre compte
que la situation sécuritaire s'améliore
de jour en jour on est loin des bases
militaires détruites on est loin des
villages décimée mais c'est qu'il
faudrait
comprendre que le peuple africain la
nouvelle génération dont politique de
femmes politiques africains qui n'ont
pas connu la colonisation qui nous sont
décomplexés qui sont facebook ou
whatsapp qui ont un contact avec le
numérique ne ne resteront pas en marre
des enjeux qui sont dans leurs films
représentent nigérien qui est
malheureusement dans un post d'hostilité
vis-à-vis de pays frères le mali doit le
plat tout faire par revoir sa position
parce que nous sommes convaincus que les
nigériens n'accepteront d'emprunter le
chemin de l'aventuré on sait pouvoir
vous pensez pardonnez-moi pouvoir
poursuivre la lutte contre les
terroristes sans la france sans les
européens non madame nous avons décidé
de prendre notre destin en main nous
avons besoin de tous les partenaires
nous l'avons dit le chef du cercle de
tahla indiqué les autorités l'ont
indiqué mais que ce partenariat se fasse
conformément à l'agenda du mali mais pas
à l'agenda
d'autres forces d'autres puissances qui
dans un passé de dessins n'ont pas caché
leur soutien aux groupes armés
dépourvu de toute légitimité et c'est de
notre devoir c'est de notre
responsabilité nous avons des autorités
légitimes irresponsables qui ont décidé
de prendre à bras le corps en situation
sécuritaire et personne ne défendra le
territoire national grâce à son jeu aqua
fait-il référence lorsqu'il justement
est bien à 112 ce qui constitue une
erreur politique plus qu'opérationnel
qui remonte à 2013 lorsque effectivement
les forces françaises font obstacle à
l'entrée dans kidal des forces armées
maliennes les les femmes à à l'époque je
m'en souviens que j'étais dans les
parages les français considéré qu'il y
avait un vrai risque de dérapages et de
combat extrêmement meurtriers entre les
forces touareg aux djihadistes en
quelque sorte et
l' efama et d'ailleurs je me souviens
aussi d'un épisode ultérieure dans
lequel un premier ministre du mali
moussa mara pour le pour le site et
avait tenté en vain d'entrer dans une de
ses villes du nord est où ça s'était
terminé dans la confusion est là et la
débâcle donc je pense que cette idée
qu'il y a pu y avoir une erreur d'
approche moi j'ai souscrit bien
volontiers l'idée qui vient
immédiatement et qui est colporté
notamment par pas mal de réseaux
téléguidé sur laquelle la france aurait
été complice active de l'essor du
djihadisme c'est franchement dire
grotesque évidemment non je me souviens
de ces vidéos où on présentait la
livraison de deux roues made in china à
des djihadistes en réalité quand on
regardait de près l'origine des images
c'était tout le contraire donc je dire
méfions nous aussi du simplisme
populiste qui consiste à donner de la
réalité une image distordue pour servir
un discours politique générale jérôme
pellistrandi alors il va falloir tout de
même avoir la coopération j'imagine des
maliens combien de temps ça va prendre
concrètement que de se retirer du mali
alors ever mwali mois 6 mois
environ entre quatre et six mois entre
quatre et six mois l'objectif est de
faire ça en bon ordre c'est à dire que
comme nous l'avons fait avec les
garnisons du nord que nous avons
rétrocéder donc aux femmes à et à la
minus ma il s'agit effectivement de le
faire progressivement je rappelle que
nous avons livré pour 23 millions
d'euros de matériel militaire aux forces
armées maliennes donc nous avons
continué nous continuons encore
aujourd'hui à traquer donc et à
travailler ensemble donc cela va se
faire produire encore des forces de
formation des forces mieux que ça il ya
un immense paradoxe début février vous
avez une opération conjointe par cannes
ça m'a qui conduit à la neutralisation
en clair à l'utilisation de 30 à 40
djihadistes exactement ce paradoxe
nombre donc non ça ne tirent pas tout à
fait donc on voit bien effectivement de
loi relatifs il y aura effectivement un
retrait qui va être organisé mais
l'objectif de poursuivre cette lutte
contre le terrorisme avec d'autres
modalités et en particulier en
privilégiant d'autres instruments que
sont lens des forces spéciales et puis
tout ce qui est rien au profit des
forces armées des pays si ça ce qui est
important donc vraiment un changement de
stratégie là tout de même changement de
stratégie et pour avoir quelque chose
qui répondent aux nouveaux besoins et à
l'évolution de la menace eric oui c'est
fort c'est choquant il ajouté que c'est
oui c'est ça fait partie du
redimensionnement qui avait été demandée
sans doute trop tard par emmanuel macron
le 10 juin dernier puisque l'état major
le disait depuis très longtemps que l'on
n'avait fait il fallait changer de
paradigme mais on est bien sûr dans
cette ce processus qui était prévu mais
forcé c'est à dire que ça va beaucoup
plus vite qu'on l'entendait on a lancé
une guerre on ne sait pas la terminer et
ça il ya quand même de l'amertume de la
part de l'état major et sa hausse a été
surtout des soldats qui sont sur le qui
sont à pied d'oeuvre mais c'est en ça
que c'est n'est pas nécessairement un
échec militaire et c'est peut-être ça
qu'on retiendra mais alors là un grand
échec diplomatique et politique et
peut-être sur le fait d'avoir trop tardé
à écouter l'état major qui devait qu'il
voulait sortir où on m'a changé levé le
problème c'est que s'est sans doute un
piège et l'histoire le dira aussi parce
que c'est un retrait forcé laon
l'évacuation de gao de gossip ou de
ménaka ça va se faire à vitesse grand v
ça c'était pas prévu je pense que les
éléments qu'elle va innover est ce que
ça augmente des risques est ce que oui
dans les modalités parce qu'il va
falloir évacuer un certain nombre de
matériels par voie routière c'est à dire
qu'on risque de retomber dans ce que
l'on a connus avec des convois
d'approvisionnement
donc là ça sera dans le sens nord-sud et
donc il ya un risque et avec le fait que
les groupes armés terroristes vont
pouvoir revoir vouloir surenchérir donc
c'est une opération qui est complexe et
que kiel que nous préparons mais dans un
environnement qui est effectivement
difficile n'oublions pas la minus m'a
mis l'homme
restent présents mais également à ses
babines et ample au monde et la plus
coûteuse humainement environ 150 casques
bleus de la minustah tués depuis 2013
dans des actions dite hostile et surtout
une minute cela extrêmement dépendante
puisqu'il s'agit d'une mission de
maintien de la paix rappelons le
dépendante de barkan et de takouba pour
sa couverture aérienne pour sa
protection et pour pouvoir conduire plus
ou moins bien d'ailleurs ses missions
que devient mélamine usma demain si par
exemple les contingent allemand 11 cents
hommes et tout dépendra d'un débat au
bundestag au mois de mai prochain ou
bien le contingent britannique se retire
parce qu'il considère que les conditions
sécuritaires ne sont plus réunies pour
agir c'est ce qui va s'en servir du mans
s'en fout pas on estime que 10 % des
effectifs de l'amisom a donc nommément
les européens vont disparaître
évidemment dans les prochains les
prochains mois ça veut faire partie des
gens qui partiront norme c est ce que ça
vous inquiète tout de même ce retrait
précipité on voit accéléré de barkan
parce que effectivement concrètement il
va il y as peut-être plus de risques des
risques également de combats avec des
djihadistes de guet-apens
madame seul la responsabilité chez vous
c'est la raison pour laquelle se pose
des questions mais vous savez nous ne
pouvons pas contraindre des gens qui
nous veulent qu'ils veulent partie où
les autorités légitimes du mali n'ont
jusqu'à présent pas renvoyer de
correspondance officielle à qui que ce
soit pour partir ainsi l'ambassadeur
chers amis bon je vous savez lorsque le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères a indiqué à la face du monde
que c'était de nous étions des autorités
illégitimes des responsables mais nous
n'avons pas déclaré l'ambassadeur façon
attendra quand nous l'avons juste dit
d'aller se reposer à paris on attend ce
qui veut dire les mêmes choses là dans
l'intérim en attendant que les autorités
françaises puissent se rendre compte que
nous sommes légitimes le moment où ils
vont se rendre compte que nous sommes
légitimes l'amateur pourra calmement à
revenir donc pouvoir continuer à adapter
un ambassadeur dans un pays où dont vous
ne reconnaissez pas la légitimité des
autorités ce n'est qu'une question de
principe on va encore quand on va
continuer
historique un style toujours à bamako
monsieur
ils sont là nous avons appliqué des
mesures de réciprocité
il ya un dialogue qui a été engagé il ya
deux groupes de travail qui ont été
mises en place et vraisemblablement les
choses avancent de ce point de vue là il
avait évoqué les sanctions de la cedeao
les sanctions de l'union africaine c'est
des organisations s'entendant le perdre
leur crédibilité aux yeux des peuples
africains parce que ils sont sortis du
cadre des organisations des peuples
comme l'indiqué dans notre hymne
national mais ils sont devenus des
opérations à la solde de ces bêta vous
même vous avez appelé le cas il va rien
ou enfin au forcing le cas guinéen
malheureusement il ya eu un coup de
force la map
donc c'est important que ces opérations
soient revus pour ce qui nous concerne
nous faut revoir ces organisations
j'aime reste trois minutes pour faire un
petit tour de table toujours sur
nation sur ce qui se passera demain ce
sommet un mot vincent de confusion
demain donc ce sommet union africaine et
l'union européenne puisque on a vu dès
lors qu alassane ouattara y était déjà
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre donc il y
aura effectivement cette annonce du
retrait de marc année en dehors de cela
selon toute vraisemblance bien on va
entériner ce qui a d'ailleurs été
annoncée de manière perlées depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant c'est à dire
effectivement un retrait du mali mais le
refrain un récurrent sera toujours le
même
quitté le mali ça n'est pas quitter le
sahel et du ca mais hier c'était fermé
se formulent inusable en variante
subsaharienne partir pour mieux rester
ou partir pour rester mieux
il ya aussi le fait que je peux penser
prédire que le président français va
éviter d'en faire une affaire bilatérale
bamako paris un huissier force beaucoup
à ça et je pense que c'est au menu du
dîner ce soir est donc de parler en
européen de parlé en europe est un
partenaire des africains d'une seule
voix avec l'ensemble de la tas de la
communauté internationale et bien pour
condamner ces généraux qui ne rendent
pas le pouvoir mais ses socios vraiment
ne pas en faire une affaire entre paris
et
et bamako je crois que c'est ça aussi
qui est très important dans la parole
présidentielle demain il peut y parvenir
général du rhdp est randy il va falloir
poursuivre le dialogue avec nos
partenaires africains nos partenaires
européens parce que la sécurité globale
de la région est en jeu et donc c'est
une nécessité absolue mais d'agir sur
tout le spectre pas uniquement militaire
mais aussi politique économique
l'éducation donc il ya encore beaucoup
de travail à faire mais un dernier mot
tonneaux sur ces deux poids deux mesures
vincent hugeux effectivement le tchad
est présent fait un certain nombre de
pays qui ne sont pas tous démocratiques
qui sont présents alors que le burkina
faso bien sûr et le mali n'y sont pas
pour ces raisons politiques et la
question me pose mes interlocuteurs
africains maliens ivoiriens
soudanais d'exclure les dix où est le
vrai macron est-ce que c'est celui qui
décide de la restitution des biens
pillés pendant l'ère coloniale celui qui
déverrouille le discours et la vulgate
officielle sur le rwanda de la
mitterrandie ou est-ce que c'est celui
qui se précipitent n'djamena seul chef
d'état occidental dans le genre pour
adouber ce qui reste une succession
dynastique donc plus un coup de casernes
qu'un coup d'état mais donc je vais bien
sûr et ça ça brouille considérablement
le message français auprès des jeunes
des africaines j'en suis témoin ça
brille également peut-être ce sommet
demain on se passer de l'armée
tchadienne qui est donc on connaît les
qualités c'est aussi ça le problème
c'est ça le problème vous pensez il y a
beaucoup de travail et n'oublions pas
tous nos soldats morts sur le théâtre et
n'oublie chez qui se sont sacrifiés pour
assurer la sécurité de cette région
merci d'avoir été avec nous nos msaa
remercie d'avoir été avec tant directs
donc du mali merci vincent du jeu merci
beaucoup général jérôme pélisse tron dit
merci cyril cyril vaillant et merci à
vous tous deux heures suivis reste avec
nous sur france 24
[Musique]